Film Courage: How does a character arrive
for screenwriters?
Is it something that is very vivid in their
mind like this is almost a real person even
though it is not?
Or is it a hazy, vague thing that develops
over many drafts?
Paul Joseph Gulino, Associate Professor at
Chapman University Dodge College of Film and
Media Arts: I think ultimately it’s going
to depend on the writer and I have know writers
that have a great character and they just
want to see what kind of circumstance would
be right for this character to explore.
In fact Frank Daniel [Paul’s former Columbia
mentor] used to say that you could see a story
as a scientific experiment where you take
a known substance and an environment that
you know and you put them together and you
see how they react, found out what happens.
Some people will say this great character
what kind of circumstance would challenge
them the most and make them explode basically.
But most people tend to come up with a story
I find first and they explore what kind of
character can that be and would work for my
story that I have.
And in terms of how different writers work,
I know some writers will base it on a person
they know and sometimes that is very useful
and the advantage of that even though the
person they know has nothing to do with that
kind of story is that they can get real specific.
Because you know that character, you know
how they are, they are capable of some things,
they are not capable of other things.
But I’ve been in a situation where we based
a person on a script that was in the story
and at the end of the story.
And at the end of the draft I was like “That’s
not the right person for that story.”
So I wound up going through I called it a
major character-ectomy.
I changed the…
Film Courage: Ouch!
I bet that hurt.
Paul: Right, well actually it worked out in
the end.
So different writers have different processes.
But the key for me is to make it as specific
as you can.
I do have student who will say “He’s 19
and a typical Freshman.”
And it’s like, there is no typical Freshman.
There is no typical anything.
Everybody is a little…everybody is unique
and you look for that.
But so yes, that’s been my experience.
Film Courage: What about the science of connecting
to character?
Paul: That is something that we again dedicate
a chapter to [in Paul and Dr. Connie Shears
book entitled The Science of Screenwriting:
The Neuroscience Behind Storytelling Strategies].
One term that gets used that I think can limit
imagination is the idea of a hero.
We’ve talked about the Hero’s Journey
and then people say well if I’ve got a hero,
the connotation of is someone who is heroic.
Someone who is likable and does brave things.
That’s not necessarily what is meant by
the Hero’s Journey but that’s the connotation
that people have.
And the fact is that people tend to like to
watch people with flaws and you don’t want
to eliminate that.
You have people that aren’t necessarily
admirable.
In fact one theory we talk about, a psychologist
by the name of Jonathan Gottschall has a book
on this is that we watch characters that are
flawed because we learn from them.
That again (and I can get you the exact psychologist
who said it) he said “Stories are flight
simulators for life.”
A flight simulator so you can make mistakes
and not crash.
And a story is watching other people make
mistakes so you can learn to not do those
things.
And so the question of does you character
have to be likable?
Well the answer is it’s all about the primacy
effect (first impressions).
In the example of J.P. McMurphy in ONE FLEW
OVER THE CUCKOO’S NEST.
How likable is someone who has committed and
who gets into fights all the time and is in
jail and slacks off and doesn’t want to
work, just wants to play cards.
You tell someone “You know I’ve got this
character..”
I don’t want to spend time with that character,
that’s who he is.
But when you first meet him he’s not doing
those things.
When you first meet him he’s being released
and he’s whooping it up for joy and then
he is out there hanging out with people and
trying to encourage people and looking at
cards and things.
So our first impression of him is that and
that allows us to bond with him and then in
the course of the story we get to see his
flaws come out and how they play into the
circumstance of that movie.
That movie En Brouge is the same thing.
You have a hired gun and now he’s wondering
what to do but you don’t know that when
you first meet him he’s like a little boy
complaining that he’s stuck in this place
looking at museums and there is a dark side
to it but we get to know him that way and
then we gradually learn about him and by then
we’re on his side.
But the question of connecting to a main character
is what exactly happens (we talk about it
in the book).
There are different theories.
There is this idea that you like a character
so you sympathize with them.
But there is also a theory that you become
the character.
That you literally go through a process that
one theorist argues is the basis for morality.
Where you go through a process where you can
feel the pain that the other person feels.
Like the example given is the other person
decides that she is going to hurt the man
near her and then imagines what it would be
like to be hurt and imagines that they are
the ones being hurt and feels the pain and
says “No!
Not going to do it.”
So it’s more than just liking a character.
It’s actually a process by which you merge
and become emotionally connected.
I don’t know if we talked about this in
the book but there’s this notion of mirror
neurons, too (in the brain).
That
looking at someone eating a chocolate pie
fires the same pleasure neurons in your brain
as you eating it so that you…it’s not
subtle science as of yet but there are strong
connections that audiences make with the character
that allows them to go on this journey and
purge themselves of emotion.
As Aristotle said many years ago and I think
this poses a challenge (oddly enough) for
virtual reality a few years ago they were
really struggling with a way to make it a
mass consumption hit like you have JAWS or
STAR WARS.
Or at the movie theater you will have a similar
thing going on with public theater where they
are doing something and the problem with that
is that when you surrender to a movie character,
you are surrendering.
You’re not there anymore, you stop existing
and you don’t have agency.
You don’t do anything, you are just watching
it, you’re just enthralled with it and you
are it.
But if you’re in virtual reality you still
have agency.
You are not the person there, you are still
making decisions.
So you are inevitably pulled out of it and
great for a game (I’m glad they haven’t
developed them too far because I would never
do anything but play virtual reality games).
It’s wonderful but this process of audience
connection with character whether it’s with
movies or storyteller involves real close
connection and therefore learning and you
see a character go through what we call character
arc when they become consciously aware of
something they didn’t know before that’s
a lesson they have to learn.
Or you have a tragedy where the character
never learns but we learn that they did something
that they couldn’t recover from (they didn’t
learn in time).
Or you get something really twisted like [ONE
FLEW OVER THE] CUCKOO’S NEXT and we don’t
want him to learn.
It’s a tragedy that happens but something
else happens so there is variations that.